hi Daria hmm so this week's cover is on
Viacom yes Viacom brought you such great
shows as Daria south mark beavis and
butt-head but recently they haven't been
doing so well I guess not I don't think
it's working out tricky oh yes actually
Dargan yeah we just wanted to portray
them as like um sad losers a little bit
because I com really hasn't had any hit
shows and show them behind when they
launched Jersey Shore yeah so we picked
like all pretty much the most iconic
characters from the 90s and then you
actually created all these paper mache
characters i did with a lot of help from
my team yeah so over the cover we have
Beavis and Butthead and they're sort of
in like this grim alley it looks kind of
like Skid Row yeah and then you have
this kind of like hand run type which
kind of riffs on their logo which is
kind of like hand-drawn and MSC yeah
it's kind of like you know they're
useful style that they're those story
goes into how like Viacom and a lot of
other companies are just like really
struggling to keep like kind of young
people's attention because raw like oh
he's distracted especially cable TV
doesn't quite have the power in one's
head so pretty much our domestic cover
for international cover we did something
completely different yes a bit more
serious which is Greece so we pretty
much went with like the simplest
possible approach we avoided like all
Greek imagery all week ropes and just
pretty much it with typography one of
the ideas in the piece is that like the
rest of Europe kind of hates Greece
right now like like they all aren't
interested in saving it you know a lot
of them have expressed the desire to
just kind of let it go yeah and so the
cover just kind of gets in the idea of
like you see all these countries just
represented by their names kind of
running away from Ruiz so the rest of
the future well we have two other
features one is about the mob and
Antwerp which is sort of like a classic
k / e story that we sometimes do the
other feature sort of explores this
class for police officers taught by this
ex-cop which goes into like sort of how
to handle you know the current state of
policing which is obviously in a bit of
disarray great issue